boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
very excited to be talking about
meditation technology we have Rohan
Dixon joining us on the show hello hello
thanks so much for coming on absolutely
things are happening
it's so exciting seeing all your
progress from the first time that I
walked into hacks the hardware
accelerator where you guys were at a
couple years ago and seeing where you're
at now massive I mean you guys had 1,900
backers on Kickstarter raised over
$400,000 and have been making this
incredible product with leaf
therapeutics
so those that don't know Rohan Dixit a
CEO and founder of leaf therapeutics
which teaches people to fight stress and
anxiety through a technology called
heart rate variability biofeedback he's
also founder of the internet party which
is creating a global political
revolution through a smartphone app and
you can find all the links in the body
below get leif calm as well as the
twitter profiles the net dot party the
Facebook and LinkedIn as well so Rohan
let's start things off by asking one of
our favorite questions what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
wow that's a big that's a big question
to jump into thoughts on the direction
of our world
yeah I mean you're catching you're
catching me at an interesting time we're
where there's the superficial and
there's kind of the long-term trends
right yeah I think at a at a superficial
level there's a lot you can say about
what's happening and this particular
this country perhaps administration
you know but the long-term trends I
think are very exciting very interesting
and uh yeah it seems like the world is
coming closer and closer together and
there's some sort of emergent effects
are coming out of that which are pretty
pretty well to look there what do you
think are some of the most important
consciousness-raising tools that we have
that we need a spread that's a great
question
yeah one really simple
consciousness-raising tool that a lot of
people are already familiar with is just
connection human connection with your
family with people that you love that's
a huge one and really really important
another one that is you know people talk
about trying meditation and what is that
and things like this but a lot of those
attentional practices that's in some
cases are very old can be really helpful
in terms of changing how you perceive
things and let it go things that might
be working for you and I mean we're such
a cognitive animals sometimes it's easy
to get stuck in our heads so it's
important to take a step back and then I
know you're big on this connection to
nature I feel like that's another huge
one and we got to get out into the
natural environment and reset ourselves
a little bit so those are three that I
really like that resonate with yeah I
agree those are massive and many people
especially the indigenous elders from in
the world are saying that our
disconnection from nature is the reason
why we have so many of the issues that
we have in our civilization we're now
stacked into these artificial cities and
the metropolis is away from starlight
away from growing food on farms all
these types of things and and then when
we have the disconnect from human
connection and love and empathy as well
with the new behind the keyboard
lifestyles yeah so to be very vigilant
with these things and to remember to go
back and and kind of like go back and
fetch it fetch these ancient
technologies the meditations the
nature's the IDA eyes yeah our ancestors
would be proud of us if we did so as we
build the singularity in the Silicon
Valley
yeah rollin let's get into the journey
so you're born of Chicago and then you
ended up doing cognitive neuroscience at
Northwestern how did you end up picking
your insurer picking up your interest
when you were a kid yeah
gosh as a kid I was super into science
very excited about science I would like
to spend time in the library's reading
and learning and but I mean my kind of
transformative experience it was maybe
15 somewhere around there where I got I
got super depressed and kind of anxious
just about the world in general ed
started reading the newspaper and this
is before the internet was everywhere
reading newspapers oh gosh there's a lot
of inequity it's just in the world you
know it was it was a very depressing
kind of realization to say oh wow like
we're all doing well here in this where
we are in my neighborhood here and in
the States and then just across this
ocean over here people are starving and
in some cases you know even closer than
that
so yeah I mean there was a crisis of
faith in humanity really and so that was
the beginning point for me for a lot of
stuff including kind of this journey
with Leif and and learning about
meditation because I found a book about
meditation and uh that really changed my
life and yeah Wow
yeah 15 to get the awakening of of
inequities around the world is massive
and it can then guide our trajectory on
a path of trying to help uplift all
those around the world including
ourselves in our communities but all of
those around the world in doing that
most effectively is another question
with this idea of effective altruism how
do you
actively uplift those around the world
these types of questions and then what
were you doing with your research days I
was looking this up at Stanford and
Harvard there was a lot of neuroimaging
happening there was a lot of
understanding resting-state networks and
functional imaging of altered states of
consciousness be like coma epilepsy as
these are these types of things to teach
us about what those days were like yeah
absolutely I mean it actually goes to
your point about you know what is the
most effective means to to help yourself
to help us and doubt the people around
us and you know we live in the age of
science and so meditation is a very old
thing but it turns out there's a bunch
of attentional practices and things that
actually work in there that are based on
our biology and so that's actually
that's why I became a neuroscientist and
so what we were studying at Harvard and
Stanford was the structural
underpinnings of different states of
consciousness and in some cases you know
meditation was one of those long-term
meditators how do their brain networks
change all with the goal of saying okay
well what are the actual quantitative
measurable things that we can kind of
say about meditation like beyond you
know what might be considered myth by
some people or or a legend and how can
we make it real for people and then what
would be what did you see with like
long-term meditators brains oh man I
mean the first thing that's like that's
kind of funny but also was very annoying
to me was how happy they were all the
time yeah yeah I mean I guess when when
you're in a state where you're kind of
stressed out or like not feeling that
great yeah the contrast was somebody
who's very very at peace with themselves
and
and calm yeah I think it you know makes
an impact on you so if that made an
impact on me and then when we were
looking at their brains of course a lot
of us ended up getting published later
and you know newspapers and in big
publications which is great but yeah I
mean their brains are very very
different it's uh it's interesting and
exciting to see that attentional
training practices can change the
physical structure of your brain change
white matter tracks change how thick
your gray matter is in different places
all that kind of stuff there's like one
foot that's in meditation and moment to
moment bliss and unbounded wholeness and
then there's what's crazy is that this
brings us back to what you were learning
when you were fifteen is that you have
to almost have one foot also in activism
you have to like balance those two
things because if we're just in a state
of the unbounded wholeness unity then
how are we making steps to make sure
that people around the world have
eradicate suffering increased though
they're attractive meeting yeah that's
such a key point I think it's something
a lot of people miss this is now coming
around in this country though right
there was an article that was floating
around recently called kind of calling
out the mindfulness culture and and
making this point that basically you
know if you're using meditation as a
salv one two
you know decrease stress and a job that
you probably shouldn't be at or is
inherently perhaps you know pushing you
in ways you shouldn't be pushed then
maybe that's not that helpful but your
point is even more fundamental like you
know we have with leaf or technology or
kind of meditation technology we were in
Texas in San Antonio for like a couple
months earlier this year and giving
mental health services to people who are
mostly on Medicaid and below the you
know they're struggling they're they're
below the poverty line are close to it
and you know there's only so much you
can do to help somebody that's internal
because I think you need both you need
the you need the supporting structure of
the society right
promote the right conditions for your
inner inner peace and well-being to
blossom - yeah yep that's another way to
look at it is also that there's this
inner drive towards peace and unity but
there also needs to be a social fabric
that enables that more easily and then
what was brain bot that was for years
cutting edge neuroscience meets wearable
wellness seems sounds like a lot like
leaf yeah yeah yeah similar kind of idea
so I mean basically you know like I was
saying that I was kind of stressed out
and anxious as a kid found meditation
and figured something must have changed
in my brain and so what I realized and
working in in laboratory is studying
this was one we already know a lot about
meditation like it does have effects it
is changing things the big problem is
actually that people don't know how to
do it and and so that kind of became my
driving driving it but it so the way
that brain bought that kind of first
company in a space that I started began
was basically like buying a one-way
ticket from the lab to the Himalayan
mountains to go find those meditators
live with them in the caves and so I was
out there for like almost a year just
putting a brainwave equipment on people
meditating with recording using AI to
try to figure out you know what are the
signals in here that are corresponding
different meditative States and so that
all come what culminated in this kind of
brainwave headset that taught you how to
meditate so yeah and that was that was
brain bought and we ended up licensing
that to another company which now uses
that with tens of thousands of patients
around the country to have chronic pain
and teaches them how to decrease some of
their anxiety around the pain by using
modulus yeah you actually went out there
for a year yeah and and did the work in
the Himalayas Wow
yep so then those insights of how how
people were able to decrease their
stress or anxiety states were then able
to be applied then to this technology
that you've been licensed and then you
basically right after brain bot starting
elite therapeutics yeah yeah in four
years now it has it's been a long time
but uh you get an excited crush it on
Kickstarter for four hundred thousand
nineteen hundred backers in just a
couple months smart patch that fight
stress and anxiety and I like how you
described it as a heart rate variability
biofeedback so we also have a really
cool demo to show and we'll have we'll
have you using your yeah so you're
wearing yeah maybe I can just show let's
show it show yeah there's so we'll run
can zoom in on it to get hold it
straight up like so basically this is a
this is a smart patch it's actually an
ECG like you would get like you know in
a hospital or something like that but
it's measuring your heart rate very
accurately it's like flexible patch it's
got these little sticky pads so the ECG
eox record electrocardiogram okay yeah
but what's cool and different about this
is that it's actually got a little bit
of meditation built into it so it will
actually vibrate when it's detecting
that you're stressed out and you can
breathe with those vibrations kind of
just to yourself right only you can feel
them and it teaches you the alcohol
breathing pattern called heart rate
variability biofeedback which makes you
feel a lot better so let me let me just
take a look so alright so we have we
have what looks like a like a it's this
is very like flexible you made it flex
flex right what form to the body conform
to the body and these are two adhesive
pieces right exactly
okay and then are the electrode is there
electrode within the adhesive within the
adhesive yes so that's an PCB sticker
okay so - okay yeah it's just like you
would get in a hospital you know except
those stickers we had to work a little
bit to make sure that they're easy on
your skin and you can use them you know
without you're gonna take it all off and
then and then so then then these are
monitoring the bio signals of my heart
and then they're detecting when
if my if my heart rate variability is
starting to in this case it would be
drop drop right
so my variability is very low then I'm
getting a little there's also a
vibrational device in here that vibrates
and then that teaches me to take the
breath and then we can we'll literally
see the readout of okay let's so then so
do you sure you're putting this right is
this like right under it's going right
under yeah under your heart so kind of
just right on the left side of your of
your body okay and yeah when we have the
and we have the app up as well so this
is your yeah this is your app this is me
in real time this is my body since your
body in real time yeah okay okay wait
what's the chat screen your chat you can
chat with like yeah with like an AI
doctor or something or coach or the get
leif coach yeah we have these coaches
now they kind of pair with with your
device so basically you know people who
have stress or you know symptoms anxiety
things like that sometimes you just need
a little help to figure out how to build
routines into your life that can
decrease that stress and yeah so we kind
of pair it with your coach so you can
kind of you can sign up for a coach as
well and they'll talk to you and chat
with you through the app and in some
cases you'll do phone calls and things
like that okay yeah so it's a human
coach it's a human coach for now and
then there's also potentially yeah right
ai component - okay right all right
there's a lot of AI stuff happening on
the backend we're detecting what your
mental state is but but yeah at a super
high level this is kind of like these
are your stats okay right we were
talking about heart rate variability and
you're just like you mentioned like as
your heart rate variability starts to
drop as the very built the variability
in just the natural kind of rhythm of
your heart gets very tense and tight the
variation drops and that's a signal
called HRV which you can actually track
so what is it what does 26 mean per why
yes so that is the RMS SD which is
it's like an algorithm they use to
measure this HRV but basically it's kind
of like a moment-to-moment track of your
you're straight the state of stress in
your body and that number being lowers
more stress is more stress yeah if it's
like it's ten about really stressed or
is what is the number for really stress
it is not really stress
that's a good question I'm actually
curious what your numbers would be
because my perception of these you're
like pretty relaxed guy I on the other
hand obviously that as I mentioned you
know struggled with anxiety and so my
numbers are this is my baseline I'm in
the gray zone for me which is my neutral
which is 26 but your neutral might be 50
or 75 Oh for like really good meditators
are knew their neutral states like 75 it
could easily it could easily be that's
crazy yeah yeah so this device kind of
personalizes to you and then it'll track
your red zone you know and is this then
you're kind of like 10 minute intervals
or so or 5 minute intervals these these
yellow blue green lines at the top by
the 1 to 2 p.m.
exactly exactly and like say this was a
stressful experience which you've made
it very very relaxed and it's a lovely
talk but I mean sometimes I will give a
talk and I'll be really stressed out
public speaking can be stressful and
this will just be all red and yellow
right and yeah okay so red is worst
yellow is second worse a little better a
little better and then then is it gray
gray is like neutral and then it's green
then blue is that so blues the least
stress it's actually most meditative
right so you're trying to find yourself
and maybe green and blue most of the day
if you can right that's where you want
to try to move yourself if you're
feeling stressed out and the way that
that works is you know either the device
will turn on automatically or if you're
feeling anxiety you can just tap it and
you'll notice this is kind of jumping me
into this exercise oh there's a tap so
you just literally just hit your device
on a shaft let it drop it it takes you
right into an exercise yeah so right
what I'm feeling now you can't maybe
feel it's always long oh so you're
getting vibrations I'm getting
vibrations now so I'm in this
interactive exercise with my own body
and if this wasn't on the screen nobody
would know this is happening so you can
do this in the line you can do this in
the meeting anytime okay oh so you just
happen and then he can go into your own
meditation just completely in your own
bubble yeah of experience and so it
vibrates to tell you inhale and then it
vibrates to tell you exhale is that
balance
yeah what's happening is it's gonna
vibrate as your heart rate starts to
drop and so you can kind of see there's
this sort of wave pattern which is maybe
happening a little bit here this is my
heart rate in real-time and you can kind
of see it's 78 now 77 75 now if I start
to breathe with this device the goal of
heart rate variability biofeedback this
technology that's kind of like
meditation is essentially to turn your
heart into a wave pattern and increase
your variability in your heart rate so
I'll just I'll just do that now
I'm getting a vibration on that exhale
what you can see happening here is my
colors actually gone green already in
just a few minutes of few seconds of a
breathing with this device I think
you've started at like 25 unhurried very
big now you're up to 35 burning it up to
35 and so yeah essentially these little
doses we call them a biofeedback of
mindfulness throughout your day there
are three minutes and we intersperse
them throughout you know somebody's day
to basically help them maintain their
baseline or feel a little a little less
anxious a little less stress okay and I
also saw that the it was cool seeing the
little tips on the screen like you're
doing great keep up the good work you
know these like little friendly tips and
so then you can also then you just tap
it to instigate your own session of
heart rate variability biofeedback also
you you're also you're also sometimes
notified when your heart rate Villa grid
is very low in it it buzzes you itself
and tells you is that to do it exactly
right so that's what we call that Auto
dose and basically a hotter dose yeah
and we go so it does yourself or your
auto doesn't cuz you need a you need the
little reminders right I mean the big
thing for me I don't know if this is
your experience but when I'm really
stressed out sometimes if it's going on
for a long period of time and may not
recognize and it's easy to kind of
forget and know you are oh yeah this is
the faster like the half-life of
negative emotions is you know it's so
it's short and like we have to know when
we can take with the reins of feel of
our own feelings and like we can be
negative for 30 seconds or we can be
negative for 30 minutes or three hours
and it's up to us to to reclaim our
minds and
yeah so you can actually of this give
this dose you've like an analysis of
what your session was of what this dose
would absolutely and it's this key
biometric right I mean it's almost like
matric HR var rate variability and if
you can just make sure that you're
getting these doses and improving that
biometric you are gonna feel better
there's a ton of research now showing it
with not just stress but things like
anxiety depression PTSD
cravings substance abuse it's it's a
pretty awesome thing and so yeah I mean
we're not trying to see what are the
ways that we can you know frame this in
the language of science which it is and
get it to people instead of drugs which
are now being prescribed for so many
mental health conditions when in reality
maybe we can start to use some of these
other approaches whoa so the over
prescribing of drugs which we were just
talking about with I'm Phil borders was
just on the show talk with crazy white
stone he was basically doing like
indigenous elders from around the world
are able to do really cool things with
not only like meditation but also
connection in nature also with like just
tribe and dance and play and and and
healing in all different types of ways
meanwhile we're over here with our
mental health crisis disconnected from
nature pumping pharmaceuticals and as
our solution but it's really as simple
at times as doing this this closed loop
feedback with heart rate variability and
you can sense how you feel after an
exercise like this and you can get more
and more in tune with decreasing your
own stress
decreasing the instances of PTSD maybe
coming up it's a big it's a big deal and
we needed the help you know there is a
mental health crisis
so these this is one of those new
solutions that I think is gonna be you
know you'll see it more and more yeah
and then okay so then I get the little I
get the dose screen and then with the
dough screen then I you know I just my
slider with at this moment my mood is
this and then this kind of acts as like
a little like in a sense it's almost
like that you have your own chain of
experiences that you have can then go
can I can go back and see okay I did
this at 323 I had plus 10 at 7 p.m. and
maybe went up plus 15 yeah exact thing
exactly and so you can mean you know
yourself best it's almost like what's
cool about it is you know it's a journal
about yourself and how you're feeling
and you know where your head's at and so
yeah yeah which is it which is exciting
and I think you know what I've learned
just by looking at this kind of data and
kind of you know experiencing how my
body feels in relation to the biometric
is a you know you don't need to wear a
device forever you become aware of this
stuff yeah it's almost like training
wheels on a bike you know you put them
on in the beginning and once you know
how to ride your two wheeler you can
take them off and I feel like that is
the that is the beauty of mindfulness
tools like this of this type of
technology biofeedback more broadly it's
it's giving you something you take with
you yeah I was gonna ask you that
question so then we can potentially use
the leaf hardware for maybe a couple
months or a year however long we need to
use it in order to kind of train
ourselves better and then we then maybe
can go days or weeks without it to see
if we can do it without needing the the
device on us and then maybe if we need
its assistance later we can put it back
if we don't then maybe we can pass it on
to someone else that needs it these
types of things
absolutely and like what are the
business models that work with that so
we're experimenting with you know
rentals you know maybe you don't want to
you don't need a device forever so you
shouldn't have to keep paying for one
forever or just sitting there not
helping anyone so depth I mean so
there's an upfront cost for the hardware
if you want to buy we do a we do a
subscription where you can only get the
hardware or the hardware plus the coach
together and it's just a monthly thing
oh it's a monopoly thing now yeah it's
not a it's not like them I think that
the device was what like it was three
engine it was like three or four hundred
bucks before yeah which is a big barrier
for people so and now I can just get it
shipped to me for like what like ten or
twenty bucks a month is it so if you are
just using the device it's you know
we're still playing with the price
points but there'll be something in the
range of 50 dollars or something right
something per month per month right
where you know you may want to pair that
with coaching services as well and so
you can kind of like we'll see how this
shakes out but yeah it's important to me
to think about these kind of business
models and experiment with them because
of those yeah you know most wearables
end up in a drawer and yeah we're trying
to help as many people as possible so
how do you once you don't need something
recycle it how do you recycle yeah yeah
yeah yeah most wearables end up in
drawer that's not cool I agree we
actually have some wearables that have
ended up in the drawer ourselves as well
from like four years ago yeah you know
what I mean and we get better at that
process because these take also you know
natural resources from the planet and we
put them into the devices and then if we
just stop using them we don't recycle or
reuse these products you know we you
know this is kind of like the
the what we get into with the process of
purchasing things that we may not
actually need when do we actually need
them to help with things like meditation
technology seems like something that's
you know more valuable than an
additional watch or whatever that we
need to flaunt you know these types of
thought processes at least so then okay
so then the model is something like a
monthly subscription then and you're
still playing around with okay then
people can this is hard because you also
have to ship them a device and they have
you have to know if they're gonna you
know take care of the device or not cuz
it's an expensive device and all these
types of other questions they have to
replace the adhesive every couple of a
couple days right so we send them the
adhesives every ronald days so you have
a new adhesives maybe every like three
days or something yeah i mean there are
definitely some people who will wear an
adhesive for like months and months and
dad and it works it does but it's pretty
gross so i mean every one of the
different threshold and you know what's
important to them in terms of waste
versus you know oh yeah things like oh
but yeah i mean that's kind of the
that's the modeling if you think about
it i mean honestly what we're dealing
with
you mentioned the mental health crisis
there's forty million people that have
anxiety you know maybe 16 million in the
world that's just something that it's
just here forty million that's a lot and
like what every what yeah almost yeah
and so and what you have on top of that
is kind of this this status quo or
two-thirds of them are getting any care
at all there's out there like doing
their best and so how do you reach
people like that and i think it's you
know we're trying to try to move along
this path that's making it easier to to
use these tools decreasing the price
points getting out for more people i
mean these are so things you do
damn yeah it's like one on every eight
and that's like that's a craziness yeah
and - yeah - to get tools in the hands
to reclaim our minds away from stress
and anxiety especially living in these
times where everything's so ubiquitous
around us water food yeah
shelter electricity internet but at the
same time some people struggle for even
those things and like yeah to be
cognizant that's so important it is but
it's not to get down on it because I
mean there is good news right and one
foot in each exactly reality but I mean
a lot of these new technologies and
we're just one of them they can help
they really can yeah I think there's a
bright future for for that kind of
approach for biofeedback and specific a
specifically in mental health let's run
let's cycle through those images quick
these are also available on the website
but just you know listening to your body
measuring your heart and breath to track
stress clinically proven biomarker of
stress called HRV and then let's go to
the next one train and recover when
you're under pressure learn and control
your body's natural stress response
there gentle safe biofeedback exercises
just three minutes you do it anywhere
all right and then let's go to the next
one
and these are the real-time insights
that we watched as well you can see kind
of like that timeline from two to six
o'clock and how you're performing
through the day I've noticed the stress
in your body has increased 20% last
hours something you'd like to note
customized exercise that might help only
take three minutes so you get that ok
and the next one and this is what you'd
get when you get the package see it's a
wireless charger it's a good packaging
design yeah and then the last one and
then this is kind of what you get on the
you have the haptic engine that gets you
that vibration HRV and breath monitoring
lifestyle trends so you so you get do
you get put into the eight-week program
right off the bat so there's a there's a
built in program into the in the device
where you can go through audio lessons
on your own time as well and so that's
in addition to a coach if you want it a
real human coach you can do both and you
can also connect it with your doctor
right if you want you can yeah yeah one
of the things that we've been when
working on a lot this year is actually
getting FDA getting by turning leaf into
a FDA medical product and so we finally
I think done that now that's just huge
it's it's really huge because I feel
like you know for me I came into this
because I had anxiety and didn't find
help in the mental health system and I
think that there's such a huge need for
that and you just have to play the game
that that exists which is the regulatory
frameworks of FDA and insurance
reimburse all and things like that so
yeah so then what does it look like then
to have a device go through the FDA
process how did that work out what is
the future with that
yeah so you know what's really amazing
about about HRV be HIV biofeedback in
general is this technology has been
shown in lots of clinical studies to
help a range of a range of things this
is not just anxiety but depression like
we mentioned we talked about substance
abuse I mean it is it's not a silver
bullet but it helps with a wide variety
of things and so what we're actually
considering that leaf is kind of you
know I mentioned the AI component of a
lot of these devices and how they're
kind of personalizing on the back end
we're doing that as well and hoping to
get these through FDA in the future as
individualized therapeutics for digital
therapeutics for all these dental health
conditions anxiety depression kind of
pain PTSD substance abuse and so I think
that's the that's the future with our
company trying to create these digital
medicines basically that don't hurt you
or have very low side effects compared
to your average you know pharmaceutical
drug and are available to everyone at
those lower price point as possible just
so we can you know scale the technology
out
I like the those combined words Digital
therapeutic that's a no I don't B's
always working on that as well with the
kilee interactive also doing there's
actually multiple companies now and
you're actually getting into FDA's
medical devices is massive so then
basically will you be then we'll leave
therapeutics be worn during clinical
trials is that the idea yeah so we're
doing clinical trials now but because
the device has been studied the
technology HRV be isn't studies so much
we're actually already insurance
reimbursable so if you have a doctor who
you want to use this with and you have a
diagnosis of sayings ID or or depression
or something like this you can get Leif
for free or maybe just a very small
amount of copay through your insurance
company today
which is a really cool option for people
and yeah it's an advantage of going down
the traditional medical device ECG route
yeah this is great if you do get signed
up with Leif it can do things like take
you off of potentially the the
pharmaceuticals that may be what you're
using in order to find more meditative
states away from stress and anxiety
instead of nuking yourself you could
with pharmaceuticals you could use the
technology there's so many cool
solutions like to be able to have dark
the physicians the doctors people that
are running these trials have these
therapeutics to give them a
moment-to-moment
bio signals on heart rate variability I
think yeah that's massive that's really
cool it's been cool and it's been really
fulfilling you know because this is so
personal for me to just like talk to
people who have used it and you know say
things like you know I've gone off all
my anxiety meds and thank you so much
and this is a godsend and you know it's
like it feels like the thing I wish I
had had you know and yeah yeah it makes
it worth it feels good I love that I
love it and now like I wanted I wanted
that I wanted to ask you about this
maybe a little bit earlier we kind of
mentioned it but this is like this is a
really hard stuff making hardware is so
much different than you know just making
like software as a service that's like
so easily scalable and deployable and
hardware is like really hard because you
actually have to go and financial
resources around the world do it
ethically created ethically sometimes
the parts have a supply chain from
around the world so certain of your
components come from like our
manufacturing since then and China and
it's certain ones in the United States
and they're assembled together and this
is unlike the same thing with these
devices like these laptops and phones is
that you don't just want to like leave
them in the drawer and buy the new one
you know we got a figure up yeah we're
gonna figure out the ways to even the
tech equipment we'll use here all of our
cameras and the units that we're using
here to do this like how do we make a
supply chain that is ethical that is
better for the city ecology to play it
in that's such a great question you know
I'm really lucky to work with you know
one of my colleagues Billy freeze on
this project he's our chief technical
officer at leaf and we both lived in
China but he lived there for a really
long time actually building the
relationships with people living in
Shenzhen which is a huge manufacturing
hub for electronics and the factory and
seeing how things are actually being
done so that you can ensure that people
are being treated correctly and that
there's not exploitative labor practices
going on which is like easily possible
especially if you you know you're to
picking up the phone and you're like oh
hey random factory I found in Vietnam or
Malaysia or China make this thing that I
want to make you know and make sure it's
cheap as cheap as possible right you
never go over to actually meet these
people to see the face to face who they
are what they're you know what their
struggles are and it's kind of it's easy
for for unintended consequences to
happen so I mean I don't have a good
answer for you in terms of like how to
make a sustainable supply chain at a
global scale because we're a start-up
but from our perspective I think you
know that human connection is really
important yeah at least when you go to
the place of the other place in the
world where you're looking to
manufacture the electronics at least
then you have that that eye to eye
connection when you actually go to
factory and you see you Swan
make it ethical do you want to know
where the resources are being brought
from the models the business models
themselves are they month are they on a
monthly reoccurring subscription or are
they an upfront purchase all these
things are interesting to play with the
sea and then how does how does the
biometrics work so like this is so this
is hard stuff to be able to measure
something like ECG and then make that
into some sort of a of a digital readout
that I can see on my phone of oh look
this is HRV this is heart heart rate
even heart rate I mean we've been doing
this for a really long time with heart
rate of just putting your finger on your
pulse and then feeling how in a minute
60 seconds what your data that would
make sense okay it does
what about heart rate variability like
yeah yeah so I mean everyone's got the
heart rate right feel your heart rate
you know how to count that at sixty
Seconds
that's your BPM but a horrid variability
people don't know about yet a lot
although it's like becoming more and
more common a lot of athletes now like
are tracking their HRV right because
it's measuring the stress in their
bodies so that they know oh hey I need
to lay off my practice today I shouldn't
you know work my body too hard so it's
it's percolating out there but it's
still early days and I basically you
know if you think about what is what is
HRV and how do these tools all work
they're kind of you know basically
measuring the tiny millisecond different
times between one heart to heart beat to
the next so let's say you were at mmm
you know imagine you're watching your
own heart rate on one of those ECG
monitors at a hospital lines like deep
deep deep right and you're seeing your
their hearts beating there there's
actually tiny tiny little differences in
the timing between one heartbeat to the
next and that's the variability in the
center
and it turns out that the more variation
you have actually the healthier your
system is you want your body to be able
to respond adaptively to what's
happening around it and if you're if
your hearts too tense and the the rate
of your heart is too tight that's
actually a sign that you might be at
risk of death cardiac mortality and
other types of mortality so it's funny
because like HRP see as a biomarker now
it's used for athletes it's used for
stress but it started as a signal for
cardiologist because they were like oh
hey people tend to die when they have a
very low hrb number so it's connected to
your mind and your body in a very deep
way yeah whoa okay so then we have the
yeah so between every single one of
these we get a boom boom on the beat and
between every single one of those if you
have what is it normally it's somewhere
but so basically if it's like 900
milliseconds and then it's like eleven
hundred milliseconds and then 800
milliseconds between these beats that
then that's good that's if it's always
flat 1000 milliseconds one second every
every beat we're talking like you're
gonna die soon because of the hospital
or the hospital okay
interesting and then so if it's a if
it's like always 900 are always 800 or
whatever it is then you're HRV score is
gonna be really low super low if it's
really flexible you're really adapt like
your body's like really maybe in flow
and it can adapt more it's less stressed
it's high heart rate variability it's a
good way to think about it yeah all
right trying to learn trying to learn
since it's good we're learning to I mean
honestly hrb as a field is probably like
you know 20 years in the past in terms
of really like looking at the right
signals so I think that there's a lot of
new stuff coming out especially like
like we're doing and others are doing
applying AI to the signal especially if
it's a really high accuracy like ECG
from your heart there's a lot in there
about your health and your emotional
state and yeah stay tuned we'll see see
what comes out of it yeah yeah and to be
able to have algorithms that can tell by
the millisecond level of what's
happening that's complicated
we'll talk a little talk about that and
another program for you to get deeper
into that what's the future with with
wearables and biometric readouts so if
we're constantly measuring this fourth
dimension of time moment to moment and
we're just gonna have a constant panel
of all of our biometrics running all the
time that are going up to the cloud that
are being processed to give us like
relatable insights and recommendations I
you know I don't know but from where
from what I have seen in the field and
you know where we're sitting it seems
like devices are getting smarter and
smarter at predicting what your health
is gonna be and what your inner what you
should do to make your health better in
in real time you know and so I don't
know what was the last thing you you
like when to go see your doctor or
primary care doctor it's been a long
time right and then when you went there
it wasn't like you had a for our
conversation about referral your health
and where you 20 minute you know in and
out right and so you know that's a
fundamental problem that's a huge
problem
so how do you get around that I think I
mean the only solutions that are really
out there that I see are technology base
you know it's like that scales and so
you know what does it look like to have
an AI that really knows how you're
feeling how your health is and also
based on having seen millions of people
that are kind of similar to you what you
need to be doing to make it better at
the right time nudging you in the right
ways and
that I think would be super helpful I
want that I'd love to be healthier and
happier yeah and yeah I mean you look at
things like you know just a couple days
ago actually a United Health Group which
is like this huge huge I think they're
the biggest health care company by
revenue in the in the world and they
just got fined by the state of
California or cited for not providing
enough mental health services to their
to their patients and this has happened
for other health care companies so you
know
Kaiser kind of got a four million dollar
fine a few years ago for the same thing
so yeah to your question about like what
does it look like in the future it feels
like technology can actually play a role
where we don't have enough physicians we
don't have enough people
nurses metal help people to help
everybody and so we need to learn how to
help ourselves
mm-hm excuse when you learn how to help
ourselves yeah yeah there's yeah there's
a lot to still unpack even with that
like turning like like turning on music
when my biometrics are stressed and then
all of a sudden I'm listening to calming
music and I'm breathing and it's like a
support that you know there's yeah
there's many different ways to
absolutely explore that let's do the
internet party so this was founded and
tells us 16 so it's been about like
three and a half years now and so what
is the internet party
what is liquid democracy we have a
little demo as well to show over this
but we have a Newton is a new political
party where you decide how your
representatives vote and then
American democracies in dire straits 71%
Americans say they don't trust the
government only 1 in 10 approve of
Congress two-party system is broken what
if we could upgrade the OS of the
government without a constitutional
amendment sign in to vote on legislation
important to you via the secure portal
discuss and vote on all upcoming
legislation as well as proposed new
legislation choose someone to vote on
everything else ok so this is a proxy
system okay so let's start unpacking us
a little bit so the general idea right
now is that one of the things that even
that's as really as old as the as the
dawn of time is this idea of how to have
a a fabric of governance for society
that that is just that makes it so that
people can't do commit acts of violence
that there is someone that is at least
trying to take care of the the roads
that everybody is using right all these
types of things but it's difficult to to
figure out how to optimally run that
obviously there needs to be some sort of
like taxes to pay for those roads and
that then you need to make it so that
it's there's no curve there's no
corruption as little as possible
perfectly none but the idea of like me
becoming educated enough myself to vote
on the way that the government runs is
hard because people are choosing to not
invest the time into educating
themselves on every single piece of of
legislators is almost impossible
probably is so the idea is maybe a proxy
system which is hard because you want
people to be educated and vote
themselves but you also want to create
another degree of freedom which is maybe
Rohan's really well educated on on the
way that the FDA can work with with
hardware companies and so I can give my
I can proxy my vote to Roja instead of
having to read this legend this bill
yeah yeah yeah I mean you make a great
point I mean it's a idea as little as
time how do we govern ourselves
effectively in best and I don't know how
do you feel how do you feel the world's
doing right now we're a long way to go
from governing ourselves however I'm all
for it we need to this old antiquated
system to just go away we need to grow
up we need to become responsible we need
to stop [ __ ] around yes sir
if the monkey politics are old and so is
the war over land and religion and money
it's all old and there's a big awakening
of people saying that shit's old and so
that's good but to figure this out is I
mean yeah so what I did I did early sign
up on the platform and then I view all
of the legislature in what the state
level the county level the federal level
I mean yeah all of those options so
here's how it works basically you have a
candidate who runs for example I'm
running for City Council next year here
in the Bay Area and a candidate on this
platform will call on the internet party
is essentially just a remote control
they are gonna vote how the people in
their district want them to vote and you
know I'm gonna run and if you want you
can trust me with your vote you can
proxy to me that's like how
representative democracy works now right
so Nancy Pelosi runs for House of
Representatives in our district and we
vote for her then she's gonna put on our
behalf she is our proxy the numbers got
outrageous they used to be just 30,000
people to each representative in
Congress now it's 600,000 people to each
representative in Congress exactly it
would be I think around 8,000 total
representatives in Congress if the
numbers scaled appropriately and so
that's a really key insight because
maybe some of the reasons our democracy
is failing in this country is because
it's structurally not designed for this
many people and the
system itself just needs to have more
throughput can you really expect a
couple hundred representatives to
represent the will of you know hundreds
of millions of people especially if you
know they're I'm feeling fundraising
everyday that's when you get the
lobbyists and the corruption are you
running for reals oh yeah yes thank you
sir if we find out you step out of line
you know you know go to the dark side
I'm gonna come well you can just log it
on your phone and take my vote away so
you'll be good you'll be good but yeah
what we're trying to do is basically
target a city in the Bay Area and run
enough Internet party candidates all at
once so that we can basically take over
the whole system capture majority
control of a city and learn
hey I mean to your point like can we
actually govern ourselves what does it
look like to have a long tail of
democracy where there are not just you
know nine council members and say the
City of Berkeley where I love making
decisions but maybe there's nine hundred
people all engaged in the democratic
system to varying degrees working
together in this distributed network and
I think that is how if you were to
redesign democracy you would actually
try to do it right I mean we're not
riding around in a horse and carriage
anymore I'm not sending you a carrier
pigeon message every time I need to get
a hold of you right man I'm like texting
you so
muskets and cannonballs anymore either
that's the that's the most big yeah you
know and to your point we need better
ways of dealing with this cuz you know
worse where's the real thing that could
happen and you know we need effective
government in order for people to be
well taken care of so they don't feel
like they needed a scapegoat whoever it
might be whether it's you know a country
or an immigrant or
ever so so we can do something like have
900 people that are being that are
representing maybe like 100 or 200
thousand instead in an in an area in a
city and then those 900 people are
constantly getting either like votes
being proxy to them or away from them if
they're not voting in the direction of
what the popular vote is so they have
the final call to mirror the popular
vote or not and if they don't then they
usually will people be like I don't
trust that anymore because they didn't
mirror the popular vote so that's kind
of like the general right I mean we
actually have a contract people sign
where they say if I'm if I'm running as
a candidate I'm gonna I'm gonna vote
according to the will of the app but
really they're just I mean you can
imagine a politician doesn't really
matter they're just gonna they're almost
like a note-taker they're like a
secretary for this democratic system
that's the process is happening in your
phone the process is happening outside
of the house of legislature outside of
Congress outside of the City Council and
people themselves are engaging and you
know you might you know have ten people
that are proxy to you so you know you're
not like a huge stakeholder but you are
a you are a representative in the system
who has some weight that they can throw
around we kind of have this already with
these influencers that yeah or you know
yeah in a sense like people will take
something that someone tweets or posts
on YouTube as you know as advice for
their political decision making
yeah and you've seen that the dark side
of an influence or two right where they
make do they may do something where
people don't like it and immediately
their followers are like they start
disappearing by the hundreds of
thousands or millions and deals
disappear and all kinds of stuff so it's
like that feedback loop is really need
because that's that's what a good system
is right it's based on being able to
look at the situation as it exists and
make good decisions and if we're blocked
for whatever reasons around campaign
finance or you know money and politics
or whatever the I mean there are many
issues that are affecting our democracy
now if we're blocked on that let's find
a way around it let's create a solution
you know before things spiral
potentially out of control at night you
know this is our shot to do it I don't
know if we have all the right answers
but we're giving it a try yeah liquid
democracies very interesting project and
the internet parties really again it's
potentially has one of the lines of code
for the future which is this idea of
proxy voting and representatives
mirroring the popular vote and making it
all done through through our internet
technology so then yeah I guess I just
have one more thought around it would it
be then that you have a portal of all
the different bills that are currently
being done at the state federal county
level etc and then you and then you
either pick your vote on it or you then
pick your person that you want a proxy
to on that specific bill or maybe you
can select multiple bills and say this
person proxy to those bills usually nine
times out of ten people are gonna proxy
to someone they trust and that could be
a politician that could be you know
their Uncle Joe who knows a lot about
politics and they trust his opinion Oh
Joe I mean and their honor
yeah it's a good dark turn but you know
uh okay yeah so that's it basically the
idea that you would proxy to people for
the most part you know for bills that
you that you don't know a lot about and
and most people don't here's where I
mean just a just to kind of round out
the idea here's where it gets really
crazy because I mean I mentioned just to
bring back to the very beginning I got
depressed reading the newspaper figuring
how the world works as a kid right and I
feel like this for the first time is a
solution that could change the entire
structure of the world the government
system of the world because what we're
talking about is a hack you know not
like a negative hack but like a clever
trick around represented democracy but
dude if you look at the g20 the 20
largest economies in the world 80 of
them are representative democracies
Japan the United Kingdom think about
this not just happening here
in America in the City Council in
Berkeley where we're running but in the
state of California in the Congress and
then beyond as one country and then
another fall so the system of direct
smartphone governments what kind of
global democracy could we build what
kind of future could be actually create
out of that beyond the United Nations
and and all the problems that it has now
can we solve these problems through
technology and would you then say that
they're that making a technology like
this could actually get its what what
the what would it solve our global
coordination problem because at times it
also is like well who controls the
government who controls the media who
controls education and healthcare and
all these different sectors
entertainment who controls these sectors
and then when you think about who
controls all that who controls them
those people that control that so are
there forces that are at play that are
beyond this 3d physical world that are
at play through humans as channels that
are trying to take control of the planet
you're talking about spirit animals or
aliens from another dimension rage
against the machines
testified I mean there's like and rage
had a good point I mean you know there
are definitely you know Trump talks a
lot about elites and and there's some
you know there's almost nothing I agree
with in general okay that'd be a not
careful right all right let me let me be
careful of what I say but but I mean
there is it is true that there is a
small percentage a very very tiny
percentage of the human population that
makes like 95% of the important
decisions for everybody and I would just
posit that maybe that could be a source
of the problem so crapping now on the
inequality and and rising challenges and
then who controls them
so who controls the individual people
you know who controls the avid ones that
are making the decisions for like 95%
romulus or whether it's it's like a
reptilian I met it once I can't keep my
mouth shut
it's a it's hard to say I mean you know
a lot of these things it's easy to
create a conspiracy theory around but
you can also use Occam's razor and just
kind of imagine you know we've stumbled
into this democratic system we stumbled
into this world we live in now not
through anyone in particular design but
just through like historical act
happenstance an accident and you know
how this Occam's razor explain what
creation is oh that's outside my
paygrade you can I have to have to find
somebody else so the situation yeah
interesting question
yeah and and then also there's so many
other things that Occam's razor does
break down and I think it's a very
important scientific process of course
but it's also
there needs to be moved for spirituality
there needs to be room for creation
there needs to be room for what could be
beyond the 3d world that yet science
can't probe at yet and it's learning how
to do you think we're gonna simulation
uh from the perspective of who from your
perspective from my perspective I
possibly I don't know do you feel about
it it's uh it's hard to know what the
experiment would be to you know for me
to be able to disambiguate you know to
actually to test that as a hypothesis so
I don't know I'm not sure what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world
oh man love yeah it's pretty great right
tell us more yeah gotcha like I told you
I had an anxiety as a kid and and never
really went away got a little better
with like meditating a little more but
um one of the things I found when I was
in the in the mountains with those with
those monks and later just meditating by
myself was love you know I learned how
to love myself and like accept myself
and it's crazy but I just never done
that over the course of my entire life
and as a practice like learning to love
yourself I think gives you this
bandwidth where you can give it to other
people and it's so key it's so important
and so yeah I think that's the most
beautiful thing in the world
I love it whoo what a good conversation
bran thank you so much for coming on the
show really appreciate appreciate you
thank you thank you thank you thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on that
pisode let us know what you're thinking
have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online on social media about things like
leaf therapeutics about heart rate
variability about fighting stress and
anxiety also have more conversations
about things like the internet party and
the ways that we can move forward and
with optimizing our social fabric and
our governance structures and check out
the links in the bio below get leaf comm
as well then that dot party and all the
Twitter Facebook and LinkedIn profiles
down there check those out and also
shout out to round Vegas for producing
and directing thank you very much Ron
and also support the artists
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
organizations around the world that you
believe and support them help them grow
all simulations links are below our
patreon paypal cryptocurrency links our
design merch and get paid link support
us help us grow and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thanks for tuning in a little we will
see you soon peace
you